bts is lighting up las vegas-like
dynamite for the second night in a row
it is night two of the k-pop takeover at
allegiant stadium and based on last
night's turnout traffic is expected to
be a pretty big concern again madison
kimbrough joins us live outside allegion
tonight in madison how's it looking
right now
yeah sasha so we're going to show you a
live view of what we're looking at
traffic has definitely picked up since
we arrived here around three o'clock as
you can see the line is making its way
down allegiant stadium now there are a
couple areas that are going to be closed
off you have the hacienda bridge the
footbridge that people are using to walk
on that is going to be just used for
people to use just for transportation in
order to get to the stadium yesterday a
lot of people struggling out here
because of the heat due to the severe
warm weather i would say because we
haven't even entered the summer months
people were dehydrated so there were a
lot of water stations along the path
area for people to stop to get water
also you could see the at the gas
stations that was pretty insane people
were using those as ride share hubs to
get to their transportation so the gas
stations were completely packed i know
sasha you were out here yesterday so you
saw what was going down
tonight is set to be day two of the four
leg tour
the next
concert starts on friday and saturday of
next week but we spoke to some fans just
to hear how their expectations are for
tonight especially after hearing how
yesterday went
expecting a lot of people maybe lose my
ear drums tonight i had one friend that
came last night but other than that they
just said that
they were struggling to get into the to
get to the entrance
yeah people were definitely struggling
but it looks like traffic is moving
along just nicely here and you know with
the requirements here at allegiant
stadium people need to treat this event
as if they were going to a raiders game
so clear bags are a must vinyl bags also
pvc other size requirements you can look
up online to see what is required a lot
of people yesterday having to go back to
bag check are going back to their cars
because they brought bags that were too
big and not permitted inside of the
stadium again this is day two of the
concert it's a four-day concert friday
and saturday of next week they will be
back at allegiant stadium and i'm sure
the crowd will be as big as ever sending
it back to you